bonjour à tous alors on se retrouve pour
suivre les aventures de notre avenir de
saint-amand qui va jouer un match contre
howard staunton très très fort joueur
anglais à l'époque et son fameux petit
match à londres
en 1843 et donc oui à l'époque londres
c'était quand même le la capitale on va
dire des échecs mondiaux c'est là où
vivait la plupart des matchs et tout ça
et donc c'est quand même sympa de voir
finalement carlson cardiaque
caruana qui ils vont jouer ce match le
chemin du monde à londres donc c'est un
peu un retour aux sources en entre
guillemets alors dans cette partie c'est
la première du match et donc saint-amand
à les blancs et l'entâme barreau 4
défense sicilienne et il joue le coup c4
alors seul oiseau rare mais pourquoi pas
en fait l'idée des blancs très souvent
donc c'est bloqué un peu le sens de
faire ce triangle pour une basse avec
pirlo au numéro 6 non en fait ça
s'appelle le système bobigny cabossé
triangle et ça permet soit de jouer du
jeune homme avec b4 ensuite ou de lancer
une attaque à l rogge f4 ça c'est souple
entre guillemets le défaut bien sûr
c'est que ça concède la case des quatre
bons et que les noirs il a joué au 6 mai
je pense qu'un joueur moderne j'aurais
volontiers qualifié 6 par exemple cahier
c3f régie si ce remède le fond g7 est
justement appuyé sur la faiblesse de la
case ih plantain cavalli à terme mais
bon réussissent pas mauvaise car il sait
3 alors il a fait cavalier seul encore
kelly c6 pourquoi pas des trois noms qui
restent dans ses schémas même si
finalement ici je pense que ça serait
pas idiot avec des ventes et un peu
comme cavalier f3 ou qui avaient lieu
deux pour faire des quatre comme ça et
ça voilà certains systèmes plus et ou de
mort xix avant les avantages dorment
quiros est éventuellement éventuellement
les noirs pourraient faire ça mais bon
ça joue quoi baba pas mal pour les
blancs donc ouais je pensais que c'était
plutôt normal mais il y va pour detroit
oui donc il suit son petit schéma
cavalli c6 il développe attaque le pion
cavalli j-6 défendre l'option et libère
le faux f4 des six cavaliers 3 fuglseth
bon pour l'instant des coûts de
développement auprès norbourg et il a
fait à 3 donc s'attendre à faire penser
que peut-être avec tours b1 ensuite et
et bi 4 pourquoi pas après bon je pense
un truc assez logique cg3 plutôt que la
3g 3 avec l'idée de refuser deux buts
irak
et puis aussi l'autre et des ruptures
angers 3e en 2004 pourrait fait rage 5
est embêté ce qu'avait dit ranger 6 mais
bon a troqué fois f6 replace le fou sur
mason donniez bonal fout d'eux petit
drop petit rock et la couche surprenant
mais en fait pas idiot du tout fou des
gâteaux alors évidemment on a plus
l'habitude de voir un cavalier ici ce
qui s'est d'ailleurs pas vrai mais il
faut des quatre ma foi pourquoi pas
l'idée est noir c'est que propose des
changes des fourre tout se joue au
passage je venais sky prend pions et
donc ils utilisent la case en d4
donc là les blancs b ils peuvent pas
vraiment prendre ça ferait une
fourchette s'ils prennent le cavalier
s'ils prennent du fou farguettes auprès
du respirant l'air donc il a fait dam
des deux pour défendre quelles épreuves
quatre maintenant profite du voyage qui
prend des 4 et puis on prend des 4 alors
il y avait éventuellement ce coup qui
est marrant tu voyages 300 fait on donne
le cavalier états sont ils perdus on
donne comme ça pour allumer lecture
blanc et on prend ensuite en cette
fourchette
on va récupérer notre pièce demain
badiou bayonne va comme ça mais
occupions prend ont fait d'après i 6.5
donc attaque le four est le cas les c3
toujours en prise et la jouer cavalier
des 5 alors éventuellement ici je pense
que ça peut être plus logique de garder
la paire de fou comme ça sur pions
français 3 à l'ena récupèrent leur pièce
comprend du psion bien sûr meilleur que
des dates parce qu on laisserait le trou
avec le pur ou colmate et en gardent des
pions mobile au centre et je pense que
les blancs sont son mieux dans ce cas de
figure je pense ça c'est une mauvaise
décision qu'a été sa vie même si niveau
structure n'aura besoin que c'est pas
bon pour les noirs en fait c'est pas si
mal et le problème aux seahawks trop
avec ce mauvais fou structure fermée un
peu bloqué sa life est d'alger 3 alors
on peut comprendre il est peut-être les
tours et cardin est chargée ça va être
peut-être avec un f4
mais le problème c'est que là avec les
north automne pour une très très bonne
décision il va échanger c'est pour ça en
fait des objets 3 je pense qu'il fait
peut-être un peu comme d'un f2 plutôt
nous ont interdit les change ici
puisqu'on va reprendre 20 pions et gagne
à l'option des quatre vues pour chasser
le cavalier donc les noirs peuvent pas
faire [ __ ] en d5 qu'ils auraient aimé
faire et on va continuer de traquer les
cadres b 4 c'est un peu notre avantage
des espaces à l'aide
et ça les intéresse en dames g3 en fait
il faut prendre et 5 très bien joué puis
on prend kallio 5 et on voit un peu ce
qui se profile et le scénario du bon
cavalier contre coke le mot et vous
voilà gd colorier le bon cavalier bleu
le mouv fond rouge
pourquoi mauvais faut évidemment parce
que sa chaîne deux pions et bloquer tout
sur caisse blanche il a pas un grand
avenir
et là je trouve que c'est hyper bien
comme je tâtonne akena il se prépare à
doubler ou quoi dames g5 pas mal encore
attac le footsie-100 vorbe jeu la finale
volontiers h trois tours c1 il rentre
pour h deux prises prédit s'infiltre bon
et blanc au col maathai défense et une
partie qui était assez futés hockey dame
bien plutôt bien joué en fait on peut
pas gagner le pion tout de suite
puisqu'on vend un peu mais ça va être
juste très temporaire puisque quand on
prend en d3 les bleus ont fait retour
des deux chasses lecavalier et va
regagner pions des 4
donc ça sert à rien de rentrer là dedans
et de liquider d'un bien c'est mieux
regarde plus de pression le pion détroit
reste ici comme si bleu pour le cavaly
tour d2 bon ça défend un peu tout gses
bien joué ils se pressent pas efficace
de filtre pour leur a peut-être qu'un
jour il y aura du h5 pas trop tôt
évidemment c'est que l'om ça peut
traîner comme ça on chassera le fouladou
banal parce qu'on est un guide pas mal
ils empêchent la tour entré en jeu donc
voilà cdtf de et ben voila j 5 c'est
parti le foot doit s'en aller
dames c'est un édit jouer alors bien sûr
tour ses huit je trouve ça bien aussi
mais damien ok j'ai quatre pions prend
hélas prix du pion alors fallu prendre
du fou
puis on prend le problème ce qui se rend
cette petite combine tam 31 tours
prendre un café projet quatre rencontres
dans lesquelles font plus
déjà très bien mais qu'en plus les noirs
il aurait pu par exemple jeu roger satis
qui est très pénible parce qu'en fait la
tour va s'activer de ce côté il le
deuxième problème semble on m'a dit roy
g2 anticipe un peu le truc les noirs
font g5 fixe totalement la case f4 et le
caillassage qui transfère il va venir là
il va être très pénible 24 la tourache 8
le foot pas trop bougé d'un machin a en
fait on est complètement ficelé avec les
bons à rien ne bouge
rien ne va plus même pas vos jeux c'est
terrible donc limite j'exhorte le milieu
de jeu mais dame 31 pour j'hésite final
bien sûr c'est aussi un choix
intéressant pour steve est de bien jouer
occupe la colonne ouverte tour d2 et ils
m'ont clairement donc en fait c'est
plutôt une démonstration pour l'instant
de stone town avec les noirs dans le jeu
positionnelle franchement une partie
assez élaboré donc avait les contes
moraux ou placement pièce petites
combines et donc ils rendent cette
finale qui est très bien il fait autour
d un an sûrement peut-être tourné en
mieux
pour faire trop trop échec est allé
gratter le pion comme ça autour des
erreurs de défense
pour br adac le pion alors je sais pas
il a fait froid je n'ai pas bien compris
et 400 nm
logique donc si on regarde ce pur en vie
et en plus on tient on tend un gros
piège
franchement ce prêt de tomber dedans
c'est jean retour b2 bon on s'en va
tomber trois double attaque du tueur que
les taux variables et marc ela en fait
c'est le drame il ya tour est vite
tourner vite pourquoi le drame parce
qu'on va faire une percée avec 2,5
dévier ce pion est à suivre
et l'option des 5 va filer pendant
qu'une variante qui illustrent ses seins
et là c'est un des rares cas de figure
on est très mécontent de réaction qu'on
aimerait pour se venger de soi même et
17 derrida alors je dis pas que les clés
que les blancs sont gagnants premier 4
mais avec les morts faut pas tomber dans
le panneau par exemple ça ça comme tour
ces deux voilà et mais bon ça joue enfin
je vais pas mauvais il a fait rouler
trop vite alors maintenant le tour des
8,5
non enfin oui le tour huit il veut
peut-être faire son truc ça va mon bien
marché s'il veut tordre et 8 pour
attaquer le pion il y avait juste
recettes donc tour huit tours b 6e saint
amand il tente le tout pour le tout sur
des contres jeunes bêtes un joe actifs
en finale toutes façons finale deux
tours et il a bon là il a fait chier 50e
comprendre ils vous sont bien passés
mais un coup à toujours regarder si vous
attendez final vous faut juger les faux
services tice passé échangent les
dernières pièces qui reste pour le final
de pions et quand même tour là c'est un
ultra logique quoi parce que j'ai une
finale fatiha plus que les rois et les
planches et ce genre de choses dont on
va gagner c'est une finale avec avec un
ton plus où on peut se créer un pion
passé de ce côté en a déjà changé donc
laurent blanc on pourra pas couvrir les
deux côtés ils savent être philippe
donc ça c'était le truc simple pour
gagner car il a pas faire il n'a pas vu
je sais pas il a fait j'ai 5 g 5 tours
munger 4 bon ça se gagne en est bien
dans ce qu'il fait mais vous allez voir
est ce compliqué à vivre
il vend voix f5
là encore c'est pas hyper précis il
fallait faire un chai 3 pourquoi parce
que les blancs en leur temps des deux
contrôleuses et ours est évidemment mais
là dessus il n'a pas de reprendre la
torre si la dame qui arrive donc en fait
on n'a juste pas le temps pour de fer
tours sète et g3 très bien dans le bleu
contre jeu blanc
l'afev cinq tours de cette tour des huit
mois des 5
bref 4 c'est encore une faute en fait tu
m'en fallait jouer j'ai trop léger g3
est sûre visons 17h06 on est chassé
cette tour tour alors là il ne s'occupe
du tout basse et blanc assez assez bien
on va pousser nos pions et ça va le
faire mais il a fait froid la d7 j'ai
trois bons tours g7 pour dire des formes
par derrière
pas top la toiture a dit ce mail a
avancé qu est facile à ce que je vous
raconte j'ai évidemment vérifier que
l'ordi et on peut tous se tromper mais
ça demande beaucoup de précision sur la
finale évidemment c'est que de calculs
alors pourquoi c'est intéressant parce
que si on fait gedo maintenant on va
passer la tour angers7
on revient recettes ils ont la tour s'en
va on fait dame mange mange et en fait
c'est juste
on va faire dame en même temps quoi on
fait dame ya prise reprend pause 12 11
pouces et dan dah mais en fait ok on va
perdre un pur les dames et sa finale nul
quoi voilà voilà voilà
bravo que c'était une très très longue
que je vous ai montré mes trois des six
est peut-être genre de contre jour
et la grosse différence il a fait tour
ici en fait il peut passer le roi est
maintenant en fait il va pouvoir jouer
f4 enlevé le roi et exception fond c'est
comme ça
par exemple si on tente même ventes
qu'on a fait à voir avec les pincettes
le même truc sauf que on fait toutes les
dames beaucoup plus tôt et ça se gagne
très facilement donc ouais vous accorde
que dans un sens ou dans un autre c'est
pas du tout la même chose et il a raté
sa chance d'arracher le nul même ça des
chanceux au vu de la partie mais voilà
alors jours de la fin pop up laisse
prise pause 12 est vrai ça c'est fini a
dit jean la défendre la dame
bon il ya quand même tenté de faire dame
mais en fait mon problème c'est que les
pions noirs avoir tout seul que je me
les rattraper et il ya eu abandon à ce
moment là voilà il va gagner petit roi
donc très bonne partie de stone town
positionnement je trouve très bien et
c'est un match finalement que deux
heures c'est serré qu'il a gagné que
d'un point cet automne mais du coup ça a
été le la guinée ce match est sûrement
que une sorte de titres de champion du
monde officieux
donc voilà cette vidéo on se retrouve
pour une dernière de saint-amand et puis
ben je vous dis à bientôt du coup la
hauteur